as soon as Wikileaks had started to
publish the state department cables this
was also the time when Julian was
arrested over the Swedish um allegations
this all happened within a week um so it
all came down at the same time and then
these major media organizations who had
partnered with Wikileaks um then turned
against Julian and basically I think I
think the objective was to try to kill
off Wikileaks because because it was a
competitor because um uh it had
had such an important impact and was a
newcomer and uh a a threat to the kind
of gate gatekeeper function that we all
know um we do have a we have a a montage
of some MSNBC hosts reacting to Assange
I was wondering if you would roll that
Zach um and then we'd love to get your
reaction I have a follow-up question
after
that many establishment journalists in
the US consider Julian Assange to be a
criminal whose work doesn't fit in the
same category as their own no journalism
here what we have is an act of Espionage
the wholesale dumping of WikiLeaks
actually isn't journalism if you help in
the stealing of classified material
nothing about the first amendment is
going to insulate you from charges that
you stole regardless of whether or not
you publish it I mean you learned that
day one in news business
school I find this whole montage very
funny because we've actually seen this
sort of reiterated um you know basically
from this time all the way up until now
I mean it's still a thing that people
talk about maybe not with the specific
Espionage framing but there's this line
drawn between well these people are
journalists over here but these other
people surely don't qualify and so
therefore their first amendment
protections ought to be different how
how do you feel when you see you know
MSNBC hosts treating Julian nange this
way
Stella well I mean it's it's kind of
um it's a bit disappointing because the
criticisms that they um use are just
simply not true um you had uh Maria
ressa there she she was a CNN um
presenter and then um a she's a Nobel
priest Prize winner and her herself um
faced political prosecution because of
her journalism and it's disappointing uh
that she says something like uh
Wikileaks dumping this is one of the um
major U
Mis uh say distortions concerning
Wikileaks uh Wikileaks does privilege um
the publication of archives but it
doesn't just dump it's uh you know it
provides context it writes up context uh
it writes up analyses um it it um has
redacted uh information and states the
the criteria for redactions and so on um
but even so I mean all of this is really
irrelevant whether Julian's a journalist
or not the question is is Julian accused
of Journalism and he is it is the
activity that has been criminalized um
not um whether he uh falls into a
category or not uh it's the category of
the activity that is being criminalized
uh receiving obtaining and uh
communicating information to the public
hey thank thanks for watching that clip
from our new show just asking questions
you can watch another clip here or the
full episode here new episodes drop
every week so subscribe to reent TV's
YouTube channel to get notified when
that happens or to the just asking
questions podcast on Apple Spotify or
any other podcaster see you next week